yes I am John Bradley and I play some
well Tolly
Samwell Tarly is the firstborn son of
randyll Tarly
randyll Tarly is a great military
tactician and a great warrior he's
somebody who always valued physical
prowess and a military Baron samwell's
never really subscribed to that
worldview he's always been very
sensitive and very academic and very
bookish so he develops his plan to
shitpost I'm well off to Castle black is
that it's either go to Castle black or
die at the hands of his father he can't
win he doesn't have a choice he has to
be there from that point on you get a
sense of just how reliant Sam is upon
John for for support he's the first one
to really encounter at close quarters
the army of the Dead without another
development that happened in Sam's life
in terms of meeting somebody who he
feels he can have a protective arm
around and somebody he can save I don't
think Sam would have really minded dying
he believes that the Citadel before he
gets there is a place where he can
finally belong the tragic thing about
that whole scenario for Sam is he finds
he's just as much an outsider at the
Citadel as everywhere else it's not the
thing that he's been searching for all
his life he was sold a lie about he
thought it was going to be full of
progressive thinkers like himself people
who know how important knowledge and
academia can be in the great struggle
it's a map of Dragonstone
that's dragonglass john needs to know
he's so excited about that because he
feels that that is him starting to repay
that debt and starting to repay John's
and faith in him all these men are
scripts and Scrolls are rotting away I
need you to make copies of Sam is a very
very proactive character and that's why
I decided to leave the sister Dale
because the laces are interested in
anything progressive or anything
proactive Samwell Tarly I wasn't sure if
you'd remember me
I remember everything bran and Sam
although some might say
Gillian bran they discover that John
isn't a bastard after all he's a the
legitimate son of Lyanna stark and
rhaegar targaryen which means of course
that he is a legitimate heir to the Iron
Throne John isn't really my father's son
he's the son of Rhaegar Targaryen and my
aunt Lyanna Stark
his last name isn't really snow its son
he's known
Daanish bastard sir named Sam at the
Citadel I transcribed a high septons
diary he would really honour in a sacred
ceremony a lot of people have kind of
talked about the fact that Gilly found
that piece of information Sam's never
really credited for it
Sam's always said it was me that
discovered that and and and him and bran
I've divided it between them but you
know Jorah Mormont's back to Daenerys
and doesn't tell her that Sam's the one
who cured him of greyscale so I think
that in the course of the universe the
right amount of credit is being dished
out he's just maybe being dished out to
the for the wrong deed
everybody it's Charlie happy Super Bowl
Sunday as I'm posting this it is Super
Bowl Sunday I'll talk about super bowl
trailer stuff at the end of the video
but we got to talk about Samwell Tarly
in brand story during season eight in
early predictions for Sam wells ending
there are a couple narrative things that
they've been setting up depending on how
optimistic you are about how they're
going to end things or if you're in the
Ramsay Bolton School of Game of Thrones
if you thought this was going to be a
happy ending then you haven't been
paying attention it always comes back to
that anytime you wonder how they're
going to end things you always have to
remember that quote because it's so
important for the story there's a new
round of the game of Thrones book
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video one of the biggest sand wall
questions that still comes up on some of
the videos that I post is that early
moment of Samwell being the first one to
encounter the white Walker at the fist
of the first men people still wonder why
did it pass him by because they are
indiscriminate in their recruitment
standards they'll turn any animal any
human into a white so that it could just
be fodder for the army of the dead
that's the whole beauty of the army of
the Dead they turn everyone against
themselves so there's really two
narrative justifications that I can see
for George are Martin - right that
moment where the white Walker passes him
by lets out a cry in Schroth that's the
name of their language they actually do
speak but you've only ever really heard
the white Walker speak you've never
heard the night King speak but they do
have a language when they speak it
sounds like ice cracking the person that
developed the Dothraki and the high
Valyrian languages for Game of Thrones
also developed a Schroth language for
the white walkers but the show runners
Dan and Dave decided not to use it
because they felt like the white walkers
were more terrifying if they did not
speak as much so justification one just
on a practical level the white Walker
could have sensed the dragonglass the
Samwell had on him because this moment
was happening right after they found the
dragon glass and the broken horn at the
fist of the first men Samwell put some
of the dragon glass in his pocket which
is what he then later used to kill the
white Walker when he was trying to save
Gilly the other reason I think the
better justification at least on a
narrative level is the gorge our Martin
wanted Samwell to feel pathetic in this
moment like no one valued him his family
didn't care about him they sent him to
take the black his father randyll Tarly
would have killed him if he didn't agree
to do it because technically he was the
older brother and first in line to
inherit everything so he goes to take
the black the last place where you send
criminals that have no other place in
the world yet all these terrible people
really the worst of humanity with a few
exceptions like the old bear or benjin
or Jon Snow
so Samwell is at the last place on earth
that's essentially forced to accept him
as part of their family like okay you're
one of us now because nobody else cares
about us in the world then here in this
moment those supposed brothers family
members just bolt leaving him to died
knowing there's no way that he can run
as fast and keep up even their worst
enemies the White Walkers literally
death walking doesn't want to have
anything to do with him
passes him by so it's all part of his
zero arc because he gets his [ __ ]
together after the white Walker passes
him by he goes back he saves Gilly then
kills one of those same White Walkers
that passed him by then he finds new
purpose for living to protect Gilly from
the White Walkers save her baby little
Sam and warn everyone about the threat
of the White Walkers so as John Bradley
says Samwell feels like everything he's
doing during season seven and now during
season eight is repaying debts to the
people who either helped him survive or
legitimately saved his life like Jon
Snow or former Lord Commander Mormont
when he helped cure Jorah Mormont's
greyscale he already delivered the news
about the dragonglass to Jon Snow so
that was a big debt that he repaid
primarily why John went to Dragonstone
during season seven to form the alliance
with Daenerys because he wanted some of
that sweet sweet dragon glass honey but
the strategic alliance against Cersei
was also part of the reason but I think
you know the real justification for Jon
was the dragon class itself and the army
of the Dead like this is the only thing
that matters none of this bullcrap
that's going down in King's Landing we
shouldn't care about that we should be
focused on what's happening north of the
wall the alliance against Cersei I think
was just a little extra to help convince
the other Lords of the north a common
enemy to make them feel better about a
Targaryen
even though per sophie Turner and the
producers most of the lords that stayed
at Winterfell during season seven while
John was away are still not really happy
about Jon bending the knee or his
personal relationship with Daenerys now
remember they don't know anything about
Jon's true heritage or the fact that he
himself is a Targaryen so really the
next step for Samwell and bran now that
the task of finding the tools to defeat
the night king in the White Walkers have
been acquired is giving Jon Snow the
good news about number one
not being a bastard and to being a
secret Targaryen in the heir to the Iron
Throne so even though he's probably
really excited to tell John the good
news
unlike brand he probably would not wait
until John is sitting at the front of
the Great Hall with all the other Lords
of the north and Daenerys sitting at his
side to tell him he's been banging his
aunt for the past couple of weeks on the
sex boat but dramatic turns like that
like the record dropped moments to end
all record drop moments are just too
good to avoid so if they tell him his
heritage during season eight it has to
be with at least a few big characters in
the group listening and like John and
Daenerys finding out together at the
same time so they can both throw up in
their mouths in unison and neither one
has time to process the information
before they react to it the rest of
season 8 for Samwell is actually pretty
simple compared to a lot of the other
characters he's not a fighter he's most
likely gonna spend the majority of his
time when he's not with Jon Snow
actually making plans with bran stark
trying to help get more information
about the night King in the White
Walkers in preparation for their final
battles
so really samwell's value now is in
being the librarian that helps sift
through the mountain of information
inside brans head he's actually one of
the few people that knows the right
questions to ask brand to get bran to
spit out the information that they need
they established during season seven at
least on this show that the way brands
three-eyed raven knowledge works is that
there's so much of it he can't
distinguish what's important and what's
not he remembers literally everything so
just like a library or even like your
Netflix homepage you have to get very
specific inputs in order to get the
information that you want to get useful
results otherwise just like Netflix
he'll just give you a whole lot of bad
movies I'm sure you can make a meme
about bran just taking John back into
the past and showing him a lot of bad
movies just random unimportant people
through history walking around doing
absolutely nothing
so samwell's role and what he's been
doing in his arc in particular is one of
the reasons why he's the least likely
characters to die the night king can
still destroy Winterfell while he's in
it so he's not totally safe but he's not
gonna be engaging in any psychic wizard
battles with the night king like bran is
or charging the field to the White
Walkers with Jon Snow and their armies
so early Samwell Game of Thrones finale
predictions without having seen more
footage yet narrative Lee it makes the
most sense that he was survived is one
of the few
purrs of all this important knowledge
with a more modern sensibility than say
like the arch maesters at the Citadel
so one optimistic ending whoever lives
John Stuart an heiress to take the
throne appoints him the new grand
maester so the Samwell has the power to
reform the Citadel and they bend the
rules a little bit so that he can marry
Gilly formally in adopt baby Sam but to
taking things back to Ramsay Bolton if
you thought this was gonna be a happy
ending you haven't been paying attention
if you want to be more pessimistic and
think that everyone's gonna get an
unpleasant ending then Samwell lives but
he doesn't get to be with Gilly and the
baby they defeat the night king the
realm is saved but no one wants to
listen to him they all still treat him
like he doesn't matter and just kind of
push him off to the side so really Sam
Wells ending just depends on how
optimistic you think the story is going
to end for him I don't think it's gonna
be the same across the board for all the
characters like some people will get
very unpleasant endings there will be
like a couple happier moments but I'm
not expecting a blanket happy ending for
everyone like that's just not how Game
of Thrones works but post all your
predictions for how Sam wells story ends
on Game of Thrones this season the
Superbowl is tonight but the game of
Thrones
social media accounts have been pretty
quiet so I will be surprised if they do
drop a trailer what they might do is
just wait till next week or a little bit
later so no worries whatever ends up
happening I will totally make a video
for it there'll be a bunch of other big
movie trailers as well so just look out
for that stuff as long as you have
alerts enabled for my channel you'll see
the videos when I post them
congratulations ivan Rodriguez you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
Game of Thrones video please email me on
the about page of my channel so I can
get your details click here to rewatch
my Game of Thrones Season 8 teaser
trailer video and all the Easter eggs
and click here for all my other Game of
Thrones season 8 promos and teaser
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
you